why do I think bacteria are cool so I'll
give you a perspective of
versity of life on this planet almost
everything on this planet is invisible
so almost all of life is microbial so if
you look at sort of a family tree of all
of life everything you've seen with your
eyes is like one tiny little branch the
rest of life on Earth is microbial and
they microbes inhabit every single niche
as far as we know on earth and humans
can't do that plants can't do that like
I do ok between you know 72 and 80
degrees right you know bacteria live in
thermal vents at the bottom of the ocean
at hundreds of degrees they live under
the ice caps you know in the poles they
live covering in this invisible film
every surface on earth I mean they're
masters at diversity and at metabolic
ingenuity and at adapting to changes in
the world and they've been doing it for
billions of years human beings a couple
of hundred thousand years most people in
the world died of infectious diseases
right those are caused by microbes and
so by studying them and learning their
secrets and learning how they work and
learning deeply about how bacteria do
what they do
I think scientists will come up with new
medicines for a problem of global
importance and that problem is urgent so
I think from the applied side it's most
important thing in the world to work on
or bacteria or microbes but then from
the sort of part of me the scientists in
me that's just a curious person that
likes to figure out how things work
there they are so misunderstood
so for hundreds of years because they're
so tiny and primitive looking people
have thought that they're kind of dumb
and a social and they don't do very many
good tricks but in fact every year
that's it scientists keep working on
bacteria they find out that there's more
sophisticated that we ever thought and
that they have so many of the features
and behaviors of higher organisms
just less of the bells and whistles and
so I think that as a scientist in a
career like the amount that I can learn
and figure out a bacteria about a
bacterium is huge right and so I just
like working on them because I think
they're helping my colleagues who work
on higher organisms we the micro
biologists are giving our colleagues the
principles on which higher organisms
were built and so we're sort of laying
the foundation I think for all of life
and then hopefully that's helpful to all
of science
besides being helpful in curing diseases
you